التعليم بعيدا عن الاسلوب التقليدي
والرتابه والملل نقدر نقول انه شيء مو سهل
منصه جديده دخلت هذا العالم وللان عليها
اقبال كبير من وقت انطلقتها هي اول منصه
تعليميه ترفيهيه في الشرق الاوسط وجمال
افريقيا بتقدم دورات خلينا نقول انها
حصريه في جميع المجالات وعلى يد ابرز
المشاهير وبتقدم المعلومات حتى والخبرات
هذه بطريقه بتجمع بين الترفيه والتعليم في
نفس الوقت للان صار متاح على المنصه دروس
مع الصحفي الكبير ومديرنا في العربيه
السابقا الاستاذ الكبير عبد الرحمن الراشد
والمخرجه نادين لبكي والسنرست تامر حبيب
وعرضت الازياء العالميه نور عريضه
انا عشت وعملت تقريبا خمسه سنه في الاعلام
بشكل عام اعتقد هذه من اعظم المهن ومن
اجملها مدارس مختلفه في صناعه السينما
ومدارس مختلفه الاخراج علشان تكتب اي
سيناريو في الدنيا هو الفكره مصدر الفكره
لا حصر له ولا عدد ابهر نفسك اول واحد
هتبسط طوب الارض فهي العمل كله مش كانه
راقصين عم يرقصوا حوالي هالممثلين
في الوقت قدامكن
وفي هذا الدرس حاول انقل لكم تجاربي
مختلفه
مرحبا انا نادين لبكي وهذه تجربتي
[موسيقى]
انا
ودي تجربتي على
[موسيقى]
نور عريضه
معنا في الاستوديو طارق الجندي المؤسس
ورئيس التنفيذي لمنصه اهلين طارق كيف حالك
اشرح لنا اذا تقدر يعني بطريقه كده مختصره
للي ابدا يعني ما له علاقه بهذه الامور
ايش
برضو حركه كويسه اهم حركه مدروسه اعطوا له
عشر دقايق زياده يا جماعه
وكل الصبايا اللي عم يشوفونا كمان اليوم
بعيد مر العالميه تسلم كل سنه
هي منصه التعليم هي الاولى من نوعها
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
تعليم الترفيه او ما يقال يصطلح عليه
اطلقت المنصه مؤخرا بشهر ايلول العام
الماضي بتقدم محتوى اليوم باللغه العربيه
وقريبا جدا بلغات مختلفه المحتوى هو عباره
عن دورات تدريبيه اون لاين نختلف عن باقي
المنصات انه في منصات زيها قريبه منها
مشهوره جدا
على الانترنت الاجنبيه يعني ولكن نختلف
عنهم انه نحن المعرفه ما بنقدمها باسلوب
اكاديمي فقط نحن بندمج المحتوى المعرفي مع
التوثيق الاكاديمي مع الترفيه اساليني كيف
ممكن
نتعاون مع ابرز المدربين المدربين هم
عباره عن اعظم العقول في المنطقه وفي
العالم هم ايقونات الابداع هم مشاهير هم
شخصيات بارزه ناجحين في مجالاتهم بيقدمونا
خبرتهم بتعلم من تجاربهم الناجحه بمختلف
المجالات باسلوب بسيط وممتع
مثلا لو انا بتفرج مثلا كيف من واحد مثلا
يقول لك انه طيب اوكي انا حتفرج بس كيف
حذرت اتعلم من هذا الشيء مثلا ممكن يسلي
لي وقتي اوكي بس كيف حتعلم هلا اليوم
الكورس او الدوره التدريبيه هي عباره عن
ثلاث الاربع ساعات كل كورس مقسم لعشرين
درس كل درس
عباره عن فيديو هالفيديو بتم انتاجه
بمعايير سينمائيه عاليه الجوده مدتها من
عشر دقايق ل 15 دقايق
غير هالدروس نحن بنقدم اساليب بنقدم
كيس مرشات عمل تدار دراسه حاله يعني دراسه
حاله تدرس وتدار من قبل مدربين انفسهم
اوكي سالتيني انه شو ممكن اتعلم نحن بندمج
من خلال هالمنصه مش فقط
يعني نقدم اساليب عمليه ومنقدم مهارات
اساسيه للنجاح في رقم واحد رقم اثنين
منقدم بالاشتراك مع المدربين اللي معنا
منقدم خبرات شخصيه وقصص ملهمه
لنجاحات
للمصاعب المروريه للدروس حتى الاخطاء حتى
الجنبها كل المشتركين وكل مدرب كمان بيعمل
مثل بيقدم مثال عن تجربته بالعمل من خلال
والاهم من هيك ممكن بعد ما يخلص اي شخص
الكورس يحس حاله انه هو يتعرف على طرق
جديده لتنويع مصادر دخله بالمهنه هو اللي
بشتغل فيها ففي فرصه انه حتى يفكر في
الموضوع من ناحيه عمل او انه كيف يضيف
عمله ودخله ميه بالميه هي ساره هي الفكره
انه اليوم اسلوب التقليدي القائم على
التعليم الاكاديمي
ما بدي اقول بدي اقول انا انه بده رديف
رديف يكون اعتماد على قصص واقعيه من
الواقع لاشخاص نجحوا في مجالاتهم وكيفيه
نقل خبرات لهم انت يعني منقيين يعني اسامي
جدا كبيره كيف بتعتمدوا الاسامي اللي
بتختاروها الاسامي نعتمدها اول شيء حسب
المجالات
الافضل في كل مجاله نعتمد على معادله ما
بين
الشعبيه الشعبيه والمحتوى لازم في يكون
يعني شعره لازم يكون شعبيه وعنده كمان
محتوى قوي جدا مدرب عنده شعبيه هائل ولكن
محتوى ضعيف ما بساعد المنصه والعكس صحيح
كل المدربين تعاملنا معهم باساميهم
الكبيره التقينا معهم على هدف الهدف هو
التفاعل مع المجتمع هو اعطاء الفرصه لجميع
المشتركين انه يتعلموا خبرات واقعيه
بضيفوها لتعلموه بالكتب وتعلموهج تعليميه
افترض انه مو بس هي هذه الاشياء مو بس انه
كتابه السيناريو او الاعلام او الاخراج
افترض عندكم
الاستثمار الرياضه الفن التمثيل الجيمنج
اي موضوع يخطر على بالك
سنتطرق له طبعا بكل في دراسه لاحتياجات
احتياجات
الجمهور الاحتياجات المشتركين بكل بلد
مثلا السعوديه شو هي اللي بدها ثلاث
مواضيع مهمه بالنسبه لهم الامارات مصر
والى اخره الى اخره
منصتنا فيها من الذكاء الاصطناعي ما
يؤهلنا بنقدر كمان ندرس بنسميه واحتياجات
الجمهور من خلال مشاركتهم تفاعلهم كيفيه
تعطيهم مع الدورات المقدمه سؤال سريع عبد
الرحمن الراشد يمكن هو واحد من اصعب
الازباء لا يمكن اقناعها وطبعا احنا حزين
لانه استاذنا وحبيبنا وكل شيء يعني اول
شيء نلتقينا عن هدف اللي هي
ترد للمجتمع جزء من تعلمناه منه والاستاذ
عبد الرحمن كمان حابب هالخبرات انه ينقلها
للاجيال القادمه نحن اليوم عنا هدفين
رئيسيين والتقينا فيه مع استاذ عبد الرحمن
تعليم والمعرفه والاقتصاد المعرفي هي اساس
تطور اي مجتمع او اي شعب فالهدفين اول شيء
انه ايصال المعرفي الاكبر عدد ممكن من
الاشخاص بشكل مبتكر عن طريق خلق
نموذج تعليمي يواكب عفوا يواكب العصر
وكمان بواكب طريقه تفكير الاجيال الجديده
وبتتناغم مع اسلوب حياتهم انا بتفرج انا
كيف اقدر اشوف هذه الاشياء هل في اشتراك
في ايش الطريقه طبعا احنا اليوم عنا
اشتراكات متعدده في اشتراك شهري في اشتراك
سنوي ممكن تشتركي بس بالكورس وانت بتحبيه
لمدى الحياه
كيف ممكن يعني توصل للمنصه
التطبيق على اجهزه الموبايل اندرويد
الاشتراكات مختلفه اسعارها حسب البلد
وطبعا حسب اذا شهري او سنوي او اذا بس
لدوره تدريبيه معينه لمن الان انتم بادئين
بهذه الاسماء الكبيره ايش نتوقع في الفتره
القادمه ممكن تكونوا حتضيفوا للمنصه او
نشوف تنويع المجالات موعد الجميع باسامي
بحبوها بحبوا يتعلموا منها وكمان منوعد
المشتركين حيكون في عنا
تفاعل اكثر ما بين المتلقي وبين المدرب عن
طريق
اوكي انه يعني اشياء اون لاين او انه
واقعيا
يعني الواحد ممكن يخطر على باله لما تيجي
تكلم واحد من هذه الاسماء حيقول لك مثلا
ابغى مبلغ مهول علشان اقدم هذا الكورس
تدفعوا قد ايش للناس اولا اكيد في اطار
تعاقدي يعني بيني وبينهم وثانيا اكيد اكيد
ما اعطيك تفاصيل
يعني ممتاز اوكي خلاص يعني بعدين تحت
الهواء طارق ممكن تحصل
طيب على العموم احنا بنشكرك جدا وبتمنى لك
التوفيق في المنصه كان معنا في الاستوديو
طارق الجندي المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي
لمنصه ماين موفيز شكرا لك شكرا